hello everyone welcome to this
afternoon's session including the three
topics that are gripping we placed
together religion racism and populism
I'm Kenny Lofton I chair the Department
of Religious Studies here I'm going to
briefly introduce the panelists and the
order of theirs their speaking order and
I'm gonna invite them to go up to the
podium to do their talk and then we'll
have plenty of time for Q&A afterwards
which I'll moderate so our first speaker
today is it barn Shippo Lee who has his
own PhD in political science and
international relations and as a
visiting scholar at the Prince Saud bin
Talal Center for Muslim Christian
understanding at Georgetown University
he's also contributor at Huffington Post
he works as the program director at the
Federation of Balkan American
associations in New Jersey and also the
CEO of Istanbul Leadership Institute in
Istanbul Turkey today at 1:00 will be
speaking to us about securitization of
religion in post-cold-war America our
second speaker Arvind
Raja Gopal is a professor in media
studies and affiliate faculty in
sociology and in social and cultural
analysis at NYU in 2003 his book
politics after television Hindu
nationalism and the reshaping of the
public in India won the Kumaraswamy
prize from the association of Asian
Studies in addition to his scholarly
publications Arvind has also written in
the press most recently in the Los
Angeles Review of Books and in the Hindu
the newspaper in India his current work
is on media theory as a casualty of cold
war history for a book currently under
contract with Duke and our final time
sorry and Arvind will be speaking to us
on the subject of religious populism and
communism after life thinking through
the long half-century of the Cold War in
our final speaker Federico Finkelstein
is a professor of history at the New
School for Social Research in Eugene
mine college professor Finkelstein is
the author of five books on fascism
populism dirty wars the Holocaust and
Jewish history in Latin America and
Europe his new book is from fascism to
populism in history from the University
of California Press is coming out
this money and he'll be speaking to us
today on populism racism and
anti-semitism and history so please join
me in welcoming these speakers and just
launch us into physical acts thank you
very much
it's been a great conference so far it's
been so good that now where some of us
are thinking
so what's the furqan you know what when
something is gonna happen but hopefully
everything is going well but speaking at
this time is a little bit tricky first
is that they're distinguished speakers
set great things that you know you might
have thought of saying like I've thought
of saying some things but it has been
covered but also I learned a lot from
this conference that are going that are
related to might mind my talk and it's
it's mostly that Cold War is the Cold
War mentality is still continuing in the
post Cold War American that is what I'm
going to talk about so I know we just
had lunch if you're sleepy continue I'll
make sure I'll shout before I finish and
you can just wake up and clap and met
with y'all so I worked on the
securitisation of Islam in u.s. foreign
policy basically on how Islam became a
security issue in America and what were
its implications but with I basically
analyzed Clinton Bush and Obama
administrations but with the coming of
the new administration I see that in
fact it hasn't been only Islam that has
been securitized religion and how
religion has been embedded in the
security atmosphere is important and
today
today and yesterday we saw that in this
security atmosphere you can take off
Muslims you can put others or even
non-religious immigrants or someone like
that but first of all just for other
ones that are might not be familiar with
the securitization figure-eight so the
theory that I work is there are three
types of methods how you deal with an
issue the non-politician which is
constructing that issue is not important
for the public this politician is
bringing that issue to the to the public
to discuss it and securitization meaning
that that is an existential very
important issue that the high-level
politics should deal with with all the
means otherwise it's so important that
if we don't deal with that issue
immediately we might not be able to deal
with it afterwards so Islam in a kind of
way being a social issue or mostly a
political issue because we speak of
Muslim votes and stuff like or like
other issues of the Muslim minorities
but in America especially after after
9/11 we see Islam being approached from
a security perspective so now of course
the security is Asian Theory has its own
building blocks which is that you must
have a threat you must have a referent
object you must make a speech act and
all of things but those I'm my book on
Iran Islam
Islam securitisation and u.s. foreign
policy will be published next week but
by Palgrave Macmillan so buy a book or
something I don't know but so there I
explain more about securitisation theory
because it's relatively a newer theory
from basically from 1997 on now cold war
is also another element that is
important for for the speech and it's in
the in the title so cold war is very
important because in American politics
cold war has raised a generation of
experts a generation of policy policy
makers that have worked on that issue
for 40 years so basically that is the
that is an important mentality in the
u.s. policy making it's the bread and
butter of the u.s. foreign policy and
after after the Cold War we see that a
lot of of discourse or a lot of cold war
rhetoric has been transformed
nevertheless while the main issue in the
Cold War was that there is a Soviet
Union Russia and we as America or
opposite to what Russia is what Soviet
is after the Cold War when Soviet other
is not so prominent we as experts or
cold war experts whoever they are remain
there and that neutrality remained them
now finally religion religion has been
something that the American politicians
have always tangled with so they've
they've dealt with religion from time to
time whenever they needed to legitimize
something but it basically most of the
time it did not escalate to being a
security issue for example I mean this
was even during the Cold War but
afterwards for example when
when President Clinton had to D have to
deal with security threats or even
intervening in to muslim-majority
countries or at least like cosmos
majority but Bosnia Bosnians are Muslims
when he and his organization needed to
intervene they didn't really use the
religious discourse in in their security
issues it was more about human rights
about genocide and ethnic cleansing and
stuff like that so I say that Clinton
has widely rejected claims that that
Islam in this case is different from
from what America stands and stuff like
that in when the Oklahoma bombings
happened many commentators thought that
this was an Islamic jihadist attack
whereas from the beginning President
Clinton has rejected such claims and
then it turned out that it was not the
case anyway
and then we come to the to the
presidency of George Bush now I want to
speak as much as I can for religion in
general but my research was on Islam and
I'm sure that after after this I'll
enter much more into research on
religion in general but so today I will
make many references to how Islam was
secured securitized especially during
the the George Bush administration so
the president President Bush whenever I
mean he talked about Islam in most of
his security speeches I my a part of my
what I was doing is analyzing his
speeches that deal with security and in
most of them he talked about
about Islam so and of course Islam was
associated with security keywords
although not directly accused
association with keyword there were
security keywords in religion eyes
security atmosphere that he and his in
his administration constructed has
securitized Islam what Bush and his
administration did is that they first
constructed a security atmosphere then
they gave the security atmosphere a
religious send by calling it a crusade
and in this crusade of course it when
the security atmosphere was constructed
it was easier to put any religion in
this case Islam inside of it by
constructing it as the other associated
with security words keywords and then
aunt Islam sentiments and Islamophobia
have skyrocketed well this is of course
not new in America because the the
Jewish community Catholics Protestants
Muslims Africans gypsies homosexuals and
many others had fit in this category at
different times for Bush it was Islam
and Muslims but this does not mean that
it would stay like that it was always
like that
so how security is is is maybe one of
the most secular institutions because
its security it's very important
nevertheless during the Bush
administration security has been
religion eyes so the security of the
amount of America has been
has been associated with with religion
during the Bush administration I always
thought of you know securitisation of
religion where then a professor or
professor of mine just I can mention him
so that it
pleasure is something because he didn't
he didn't really publish anything about
that
he said that impact it was John Ball he
said and it made a lot of sense that it
was security that was religion eyes to
security that became a religious issue
and because Bush has never refrained
from proudly expressing his religious
views and devotion for example in many
occasions he talked about how he found
found life after becoming a devout
Christian he probably claimed the credit
of decided to start faith-based
organization for prisons to spread the
gospel while while president he quoted
Christian religious scripts for the war
of apocalypse - JA - Jacques Chirac he
claimed that his idol is Jesus in his
memoir and that and that the story of
Moses in the Bible is the story that
made him run for president he also
believed in a religious mission claiming
that the invasion of Afghanistan in Iraq
and the israeli-palestinian peace deal
were calls from God of course finally
with which made it very clear is that he
did not refrain from using the word
crusade to explain American war in the
Middle East and in this case he did not
have to mention Islam as the other but
leaving Islam out of any of everything
that America stands for as US
constructed Islam as the other where
Islam has become a security concern
especially after it was associated with
keywords in the same species
so another thing for example when also
he was talking about Islamic extremism
or radicalism the most references that
he made were references to events that
America has already won either
Saddam Hussein or or cold war so he
defined 911 attacks in front of the
Congress nine days after the attacks as
we have seen their kind before they are
the hairs of all the murderous
ideologies of the 22nd century they
follow the path of fascism masses iment
and totalitarianism and he also he also
compared 9/11 continuously with the
Pearl Harbor attacks in his
autobiography he gives a reference to
the fall of Kandahar and he says that
it's interesting how Kandahar felt on
December 5th which is the 16th
anniversary of Pearl Harbor so what I'm
trying to explain here is that that that
mentality has continued afterwards and
this is and the problem is that we could
not go out of that mentality so of
course it's easy it's difficult to
expect less from from President Bush and
his organization because his senior
senior advisors and decision-makers in
the administration were most of them
were called were actors no one else but
conduits arise was his was his teacher
and on
National Security Adviser but then
Powell Cheney Rumsfeld they all came
from from fatherhood and even Cheney in
his memoir he says that
that Bush should have should have
finished what his father couldn't so if
we go back to the to the to the religion
age the realization of security Bush was
very serious when he talked about the
crusade in the Middle East because he
claimed that in in a meeting with
Israeli and Palestinian delegation he
claimed that that he got a call from God
and that all he's doing is answering the
call from God in Afghanistan Iraq and to
make a peace deal between Israel and
Palestine which I hope I wish that would
have gone through that problem
nevertheless when talking to Jack
Shirokov France Bush used religious
discourse to convince Chirac and I want
to call Jacques Jacques you and I share
a common faith you're a Roman Catholic
I'm a Memphis I'm a Methodist but we are
both Christians committed to the
teachings of the Bible we share one
common Lord Gog and Magog are at work in
the Middle East biblical prophecies are
being fulfilled this confrontation is
willed by God who wants to use this
complex conflict to erase his people's
enemies before a new age begins so the
the apocalyptic war and where where Gog
and Magog is is mentioned obviously in
both old and new testaments is the war
in fact how I found this was when I was
searching Google about a bin Laden quote
about why they are again like America is
against us and stuff like that this is
something that came out like well you
know things happen anyway so why are we
talking so much about about this and why
this is important well I believe that
the securitisation of office Tom in
particular and religion in general has a
big impact in today's events the
security atmosphere was constructed and
this is done by mainly three things fear
more fear and much more fear by
inflicting fear one can do many things
as best explained by Jorge father of a
single man film fear after all is our
real enemy fear is taking over our world
fear is being used as a tool of
manipulation in our society it's how
politicians peddle policy and how
Madison Avenue sells us things we don't
need think about it
fear that we are going to be attacked
fear that there are communists lurking
around every corner fear that some
little Caribbean country that doesn't
believe in our way of life poses a
threat to us fear that black culture may
take over the world fear of growing old
and being alone end of quote when we
come back when we come to President
Obama the Obama administration have have
an acknowledge that this was a wrong
policy to to securitized religion or
Islam in particular and although they
have as an administration has tried to
disappear ties religion in this case
Islam it has not been very successful of
course we cannot expect that something
that has been that has has done so much
damage in eight years cannot be meant in
another eight years but also the
the acts were a little bit like like
superficial and finally we come to
President Trump which I wish I finished
I had finished my book before the new
president because I had to deal with
looking at speeches that President Trump
has made on security and Islam so
meaning all the speeches before he
became the president before his
inauguration everything that whatever
whatever progress has done during the
Obama administration have have gone to
waste of course but there is something
there's something interesting and this
is that until now until the Trump
administration it's now was not
securitized or attacked directly it was
a it was attacked or securitized by
association indirectly which is what
what what David Hirsh did they talk talk
in the morning that today anti-semitism
in in America is not very explicit it
was like auntie Muslim sentiment
sentiments were during the Bush
administration what changed is now
people like general Flynn asked
Americans to share his tweet about about
the fear against Islam being rational so
the aunt Muslim these sentiments have
gone in an action level whereas the anti
anti semitism now has kind of come to
the place where where anti-muslim
sentiments were during the Bush
administration not explicitly talking
against it
talking talking against it moreover as
we can see in in most of the statements
of the of the Trump administration Islam
today is not accepted by them as a
religion it's accepted as an ideology
first so it does not
into the constitutional right of
religion second is because um they have
a need to define America and American
fight against another ideology just like
the Cold War of foreign ideology I don't
need to quote the Trump administration
in his in their in what they said of
course against Islam because as we all
know they they come from I think Islam
hates us to Islam being a cancer that
general Flynn said what I want to finish
with is that today we must say that
everyone has in one way or another
contributed to this security atmosphere
but most importantly it is very scary
and it should scare us all in this
atmosphere it would be easier to
substitute one constructed threat with
another it will be easy to substitute
Muslims with Jews or substitute Muslims
with religious people immigrants
non-whites or others this atmosphere
makes people vulnerable to conspiracy
theories which today have become
mainstream Bush has not attacked Islam
or the Muslims explicitly by but by
association today the anti-muslim
campaign has evolved into action level
being attacked openly directly
anti-semitism has taken until Muslim and
Aunty Islam's place by being attacked by
Association conspiracies and sometimes
explicitly I guess hate has also some
evolving levels despite the firing or
resignation of Benin and Gorka the
nationalist idealism is safe and firm in
the administration but more so in the
discourse among people now just
before I before my before I I finish I
want to finish with a coat that that the
professor Austin yesterday read from
cater 301 when talking when asked about
Obama this hater 301 said that he is a
communist dictator wannabe so I guess he
couldn't even become real dictator is
only a wannabe who has no respect for
God our history or constrict our
Constitution our freedoms our culture
our borders our military our tax money
Israel or the truth also he is a pro
terrorist Muslim anti colonialists with
an animus toward whites in general and
American whites in particular he has no
love for this country or its people he
is a man to be feared and not respected
so basically anyone can fit in can be
constructed as one of opinion in one of
these categories so of course there is
nothing good in this in this security
and political climate but at least we
understand that conferences like this
are necessary where we deal with racism
anti-semitism on tape until all as a
common question anti-semitism is not
separate from from Islamophobia or other
type of racism well thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
thank you everybody I don't know how
much time we have I've just launched
into my talk I understand the title of a
talk was always a contract about what I
ought to say but like many contracts I
will honor it to the best of my ability
but there's some deviation here now the
up ending of conventional assumptions by
recent events is so numerous and so
far-reaching that retaining the academic
high ground of detached contemplation is
not easy one has to resort to what
bertolt brecht has called in a time that
was in some respects like our own
plumpest Enki clumsy thinking in the
effort to understand the links rapidly
being drawn across realms we are not
used to thinking across very easily race
religion and government for example like
a blitzkrieg that takes the political
establishment by surprise the religious
and racial supremacism currently
ascendant in many societies claims to
affect something like a transvaluation
of existing official values and
meanwhile there is the risk of
responding in predictable ways feeding
into an existing plan of action but one
that actually belongs to the opposition
here on responding to the call of this
conference as someone who spent many
years studying Hindu nationalism in
India and second more important for our
conference perhaps as a scholar of media
history in the 19th century print
technology together with upper-class
reaction to socialist and communist
movements which gained from the speed of
the Telegraph and the railway led to the
spread of racialized theories of history
from Western Europe from thinkers like
gobino and bulam here the uptake of race
theory in colonial regions such as India
by thinkers such as Bal Gangadhar
Tillich can be seen in his nineteen not
three volume the are
take home of the Vedas dedicated to max
Muller where he reads the Hindu
scriptures to argue that Aryans actually
originated from the Arctic regions and
migrated outwards from there mainly to
India and incidentally to Europe this
was the earliest expression of what
later became Hindu nationalism and here
the author denies colonial difference
and instead implies that India's culture
predates that of Europe these are claims
that resonated with rich lish later
racial thinkers such as rene again yo
and julius Avila who cite Tillich
amongst others
Steve Bannon also invokes Hindu theories
of cyclical time arguing that we are in
the Kali Yuga the end times
according to the Hindu cosmology before
the world has overcome by sin destroyed
by the gods and has to be created anew
according to this model of thinking
whatever was first should always remain
first and whatever comes later should
always be subordinate you may say this
is a kind of aristocratic thinking which
responds to the Christian messianism of
working class movements from below we
could say it's a kind of anti media
theory rejecting the patent influence of
new technologies which allow an
inversion of hierarchy and offer
therefore advantageous to late comers
these advantages have in fact
constituted key premises of
modernization and constitutes its
revolutionary elements such as they are
there is a well-established tendency in
intellectual historiography to discern
continuities and shifts of the way ideas
passed down through the ages
but here I would like to forefront the
social and technical mechanisms of
transmission and circulation whose
importance has grown while scholarship
has often continued to treat them as
invisible props as if ideas could go
forth and multiply
by themselves as if media was simply
vanishing
mediators the knowledge that this is not
so is increasingly hard to ignore the
issue is how to understand it it is
clear that right-wing groups see media
technologies as a double gift at least
on the one hand reducing the expense of
grassroots mobilization and second
utilising liberal protections to
propagate hate and violence under the
guise of free speech it is inconceivable
I suggest that the rapid rise of these
groups could have occurred without it
across the world here I can reference
recent Hindu nationalism which has moved
from a fringe political phenomenon to a
party that is not only politically
dominant but also socially and
culturally and this has occurred in the
space of a few decades about three that
- in a country that continues to be
regarded as a rare example of
capitalism's triumph in the global south
for example India has a relatively large
middle class a record of peaceful
electoral change that is probably unique
amongst developing countries and a
growth rate that for many years now has
been far higher than that of the
developed north but together with
rapidly rising inequality hate crime and
political violence against Muslims and
Dalits formerly untouchable castes have
increased the recent Pew Research Center
analysis of 198 countries ranked India
as the fourth worst for social hostility
based on religion behind only Syria
Nigeria and Iraq now the US Republican
Party has provided the Hindu nationalist
party BJP
with a role model in combining
neoliberal and socially conservative
policies but India leads the u.s. by
some decades in providing a model where
independent media coverage and electoral
democracy have repeatedly meshed
together in extremely violent forms of
politics while formally retaining the
rule of law over the past three decades
witnessing in India the practice the
socialization of the public into the
practice of cruelty staged by vigilante
as vigilante violence we have lynchings
this extends to the the riots that
brought the current prime minister to to
office but more recently we have
lynchings and public humiliation of
Dalits and Muslims by Hindu nationalists
recorded on camera that go viral and
social media this would be followed by
lengthy silence on the part of political
leaders and instead of punishment
perpetrators are rewarded with gifts
social and political privileges and they
become local leaders and media stars
this is counter-revolution at work with
violence and criminality in the service
of moribund hierarchy being installed at
the head of society instead of being
corrected in any way counter-revolution
not only in the assertion that violence
belongs at the center of modern
civilization
instead of being eliminated from it as
for example Norbert Elias has argued but
also in rejecting reason and
transparency has been rules of public
discourse instead we are referred to
abstract knowledge that justifies
violence justifications at a higher
level that do not have to be spelt out
available to the initiated that
sanctions collective punishment in
respond to act in response to
allegations of an individual infraction
perhaps we have taken so much for
granted that progress is inevitable and
that modern institutions are at the
service of progress that when these
institutions suddenly reverse the
direction of their movements you are
completely at a loss and then can only
protest this was never the plan and it's
possible that with events like
Charlottesville we are seeing exactly
this model of political action at work
to summarize my argument in brief and
then I'll spell out some comparisons
drawing on the example of Hindu
as well Reinhart Kozelek
has observed that concepts emerge within
and in response to specific polemics
arising in history we may still be too
close to the polemics involved with
media as a concept to clarify it
adequately but we noticed the terms
shifting an indeterminate lexical
character is it singular as in the media
says or is it a collective noun as in
freedom friedrich hitler's well-known
quotation media determined our situation
our media actors or merely objects the
term exists in each of these senses
often within the same work historical
semantics tells us to pay attention when
a word check acquires new kinds of usage
historical change may manifest as
disregard for etymology and grammatical
consistency and only later acquire
intellectual elaboration at a time when
received eschatology is overshadowed by
human-made disasters and when technique
and instrumentality often replace all
the concerns of good and evil the
prominence of the word media together
with its conceptual vacuity illuminates
I suggests the insurgent political
energies we observe today with their
free-floating and protein character
their violence is obviously what gets
attention but it may distract from
broader historical understanding we can
recall that the conclusion of the Cold
War of the Cold War era led to triumphal
predictions about the end of history in
fact the moment marked an end to mass
utopias Susan but Moses argued this for
example that that is the end of the
widespread belief in collective
emancipation fostered by technologies of
the modern state as practices and
technologies of abstraction and
mediation have proliferated over the
19th and 20th century however they also
generated their
the sense of an unmediated relation to
the benefits of modernity and of
alternative forms of belonging we could
say that utopias have continued to
emerge disparate mutually irreconcilable
progressive and regressive both given
scholarly preoccupation with the high
politics of the state they have not
gained much scrutiny until they've
become violence perhaps extinguishing
the spectre of communism may have led to
the failure of the illusion named
communism but the specter of unmediated
collectivity is alive and well and both
the passionate energy and the enormous
neighbor team of those subscribing to
such collectivities is in part a result
of the way in which the Cold War was
fought and won I suggest and here I have
a line from the poet John Ashbery
forget as we will something soon comes
to stand in their place not the truth
perhaps but yourself it is you who made
this but the truth has passed on to
divide us all close quotes so my
argument is working through three
categories Cold War media and religion
I've introduced each of them I'll say a
bit more about them now now to invoke
the Cold War Asst is liable to put most
audiences on guard in part because the
scholarship was conducted by experts
who'd never predicted its end but very
briefly if the aim of the Cold War was
to fight communism religion was regarded
as a benign ally in that war and as a
realm of morality
divorced from politics and capable of
judging it
deepening a long-standing contradiction
that undercut the division between
private and public over time leading to
its increasing importance in the public
sphere in Cold War language this is what
is known as blowback we've seen it in
many places from the Middle East to
South Asia to the United States itself
State Department reports on the Hindu
right-wing organization that know
Moodie present Prime Minister of India
and other leaders of the present
government are members of such reports
on the hints right-wing organization
over the 50s and 1960s repeatedly argued
that it was a harmless group focused and
religious faith in fact on Hindu revival
they failed to notice that this
organization actually avoided all
symbols and rituals of Hindu faith and
in any case Hindus Hindu faith did not
read need revival was alive and well
interestingly there was no linking back
to these older reports when large-scale
violence was caused by these groups
either by the State Department or by
independent Indian scholarship rise of
internationalism as a whole was viewed
indulgently partly because of its
anti-communism and its eager cultivation
of big business as well as its strong
presence in the US diaspora five minutes
right okay so my second category media
the relation of this term to the Cold
War has largely centered in the question
of propaganda pro or anti communist but
a more important development that took
place during the Cold War has largely
been ignored namely the intensive
promotion of the instruments of
propaganda namely mass media instead of
being treated as agencies of the state
they were proclaimed as emblems and
agents of freedom and his enemies of
authoritarianism here media are seen as
or should be understood as receptacles
of modern subjectivity from the print
revolution on words but not considered
investigating worth investigating on
their own or to put it another way they
were also phenomena that disappeared
into their concepts which in turn
telescoped into idealize understanding
of modern society similarly we might say
the question of religion and with it of
religious difference disappeared into
what was the presiding term namely
secularism which was considered a fait
accompli rather than being a precarious
fiction maintained between church and
state that could not withstand close
examination so to my task of comparison
very briefly and abbreviated Li I
suggest that it's obvious the United
States is also a post-colonial Society
it was after the first post-colonial
society and it's useful to consider what
this to undertake the task of comparison
not from the US outwards as it's
typically done from the outside inwards
what we can learn from from such a
comparison thus it is in the global
periphery that when one can appreciate
more recently more easily the recency of
secularism as a policy and it's
relatively weak hold on society and we
should we can recall here that the u.s.
is in fact distinct from Western Europe
in that its political revolution was not
achieved as a freedom from religion but
the freedom for religion yeah and in
this sense it is symptomatic of many
other colonies not all but certainly of
India yeah so and Hannah Arendt has made
this remark that for all the importance
and brilliance of the American
Revolution its founders once the
revolution was accomplished turn their
backs of the rest of the world
and focused on building their Republic
to the detriment certainly of political
theory in political history yeah but
with this recent appearance of a return
to isolationism that we seem to be
witnessing here together with the
develop
deliberate blurring of perception and
reality we can consider at least three
interrelated trans valuations that are
going on of though as far as I can ins
the time I have first values are
exercised as claims which can stand for
facts the adequacy of their
representation is not challenged in fact
it doesn't appear even to get taken as
an issue that requires to be discussed
coherent logic as was mentioned
yesterday is not necessarily an issue in
fascist doctrine second the Hobbesian
social contract usually held to
underwrite the modern era which
relegates differences of religion to the
private sphere he's rejected here now
Hobbes had sought to replace the fact of
political conquest with the rule of law
right so in England the Norman Conquest
was being replaced by the rule of law
with his argument about a social
contract but what we have with recent
events is a return to what Michel
Foucault has called the social war
discourse the social war discourse
replaces a rule of Florida's course yeah
third the Westphalian piece which
opposed the principle of kuya's vague
you may use elidio whose realm his
religion thus of national sovereignty
signaled the end of the era of total war
and this is of course linked to the
Hobbesian social contract now
contemporary reaction claims to want to
end this more than 300 year old pact and
return to the era of total war where
politics and morality are fused together
just as during the medieval Crusades now
all of this adds up to a very tall order
indeed more than what was presented in
Trump's campaign players certainly and
probably more than we can close this
door probably more than the majority of
his electorate bargain for since they go
together with promises of more jobs and
deal making with foreign countries that
will make
America great again they're also as
robert kuttner as remarked all over the
map they do not survive close inspection
but their power lies more in disruption
than in reconstruction
we essentially appear to have high
impact narratives that looked like they
might have been shaped in Hollywood
I wrote this before but paper one of the
papers yesterday Jeff Alexander dealt
with an argument like this we are
dealing with high impact narratives that
might have been shaped in Hollywood and
pre-tested in one or other segments of
the entertainment industry such as
gaming of course Steve Bannon worked in
the power of these narratives is
measured by their success in the
attention economy which bypasses the
liberal model of the public sphere truth
does not correct error so much as
decline in relevance as the quality of
information circulating increases a new
addendum to the parliamentary model
namely ratings alters the nature of
public debate in ways that tend to favor
Free Riders outsiders and disruptors
over those subscribing to institutional
reproduction this is a reminder that the
evolution of what Hans Magnus
engines Berger called the consciousness
industry has not surprisingly implied an
enormous political power one that was
assumed to be safely sequestered in an
extension of the separation of powers
argued for by Montesquieu later by the
Federalist Papers the assumption that
there will be a Fourth Estate that would
counterbalance the government but which
would itself stay in its place was akin
to a kind of religious belief in the
power of institutions that will simply
reproduce themselves as they were made
now in mass mediated environments the
imagination of consensus is magnified
many fold
and thus the shock of an attack and the
values of the system has an explosive
impact for verrilli or the spoke of an
information bomb capable of going where
explosives had never been able to go
into people's minds and thus into
everything they perceive contemporary
right-wing theorization of the media
saturated as it is with the discourse of
total war has largely because of its
pariah status been far more adept at
designing itself as something like an
information bomb or to switch the
metaphor as a contagion as information
you feel you need to protect yourself
but in fact it attacks your immune
system the real defense would be then to
exclude its circulation altogether but
only the enemies of liberal democracy
were supposed to undertake censorship so
this is the kind of dilemma were left
with and have to wrap up so thank you
very much
[Music]
okay well I'm very happy to to be here
and basically I think even the topic of
the conference and the current anxieties
about what's going on right now some of
the questions of the conference applied
to a reality that we live I think every
minute and let's say from the academic
side this is done in a context where
we're now there is a you know a very
important interest on issues like
populism fascism racism and is quite
understandable I mean it's quite
understandable and to the extent that
this conference can even reenergize that
interest
are we moving from let's say a state of
melancholia or even anxiety to to a
state in which the Academy can provide
some sort of understanding of what's
going on or that response not an answer
of what these guys going to do or not we
don't know that we are surprised every
minute about you know whether what he
writes on what he decides with important
and even dramatic consequences for a lot
of people probably not us but or not
many of us or perhaps you know in the
future some of us who knows so basically
this we are talking about the topic that
has in the current situation at least in
this country a kind of emergency status
and there why there is an a kind of
understanding that we should have a
visibility frustration I mean among many
of us or even the public at large when
we speak and we don't provide an answer
of what's going on with the world and
especially in America and especially
with the coalition that we have
currently at the White House now I like
all the specialists that talk to you in
this conference and
I learn a lot myself from them I come to
talk basically as an expert on this
topic it's not that I became yesterday
an expert on fascism and populism it's
not that I we came yesterday an expert
on this because of Donald J Trump in
fact this is I'm very happy to say my
book number six on the topic and it came
in in a moment which which demands
explanations that I think as scholars
and certainly as historians we cannot
provide and yet I think moments like
this basically show why we need history
so my simple message to my colleagues
out there that are becoming now experts
on the topic I have a very simple
message do what we do do your homework
and read history and I don't mean just
study the historical record but just
real the incredible amount of Tokyo of
words on the subject I mean that is a
starting point I mean it's not that they
will give you an answer but then you
will see okay I see something new here
and yet I see important presence for
thinking what's going on now starting
with that I will say this
a a sanic story and I am quite
frustrated with the blog Rafi that's why
I wrote this book I mean with the
subtitle in history because I felt that
these two topics fascism and populism
would analyze to a great extent
theoretically being in the sense that
they were combined in the analysis and
not so much historically many of my
colleagues were studying one or the
other and they were not combining them
and a perhaps because their own
frustration with the lack of history in
the theory they did not pay too much
attention to the theory itself and there
is something to be gained why not
going out and you know engage in other
disciplines so basically my project was
about or is about trying to see what
happens when history and theory meet a
word and how actually in this current
state not yet of emergency in the legal
sense but a state of emergency in every
other sense
what happens I mean and what kind of
interpretation can be provided and to
understand what's going on now from the
theoretical side and I will I will be
somehow hyperbolic and probably unfair
but I will say that there are a lot of
theories even definitions of both
fascism and populism without history and
what I mean by that is that when you
approach this from a historical
perspective and this is you know our
students are many times frustrated by
this because we insist things are
complex they cannot be killed or
determind by two or three or four
sentences in a definition and then the
students said say to us okay give us
your definition and we say no the
problem is that you know there are
continuities and changes and it's very
hard to really reduce very complex
histories which are both national and
transnational - a kind of one minute
explanation I mean that is I think that
will sum up what I think I mean many of
my historians colleague thing and yet
our emphasis on the history connects to
the particular thing that when you study
the history of this phenomena basically
you see that they're first they are
combined they are part of the same let's
say to put it in terms of a service
chemicals major war combos fascism and
the intent Lichtman they are part of the
same response blog responds to more
democracy but these are responses which
are often connected often synchronic
as we speak now they are even part of
power collisions and yet they are very
different meaning that a populace is not
a fashion they can be allies and yet
it's not the same and in fact also
chronologically it is one that emerges
before the other
I mean it's populism that first comes as
a response to problems in a modern
democracy or what they see as presence
in modern democracy and then fascism in
a way learning from that master so to
speak you know appears with a very
different response very different
response and then after that populism
comes back
and that but my after that I mean 1945
when fascism is defeated I will be a
little bit more specific about about
some historical record here but it shows
when I provide a kind of spectrum for a
second
and finally the current situation in
which it seems I mean and that sense of
it seems actually I think cannot be just
discarded it seems that fascism is
coming back so these are this a long
history of let's say modern responses to
modern democracy the first responses are
as I said you know I would say sorry to
my particularly American or Russian
history colleagues that I study populism
in the 19th century they are not that
important why I mean why because they
were not empowered and they were
opposition movements so in a way you
might say that in the form of a modal
response to modern democracy populism
was not successful by the end of the
19th century and the early 20th century
other more classical responses happened
to democracy for example colonization
dictatorship many other things but not
populism perhaps he was as they say
young and inexperienced them and fascism
appears by the light by the 1920s and of
course it learns from the populist
experience who can deny that this
mayoral candidate who actually in a way
a right to power as the mayor of Vienna
tableau a girl but and who could could
deny that was an influence for Hitler
but what is interesting is that Norma
was a populist in the position but when
he was a major or than the Semitic stuff
that he said which was at the center of
the campaign was not that important so
in a way that is a case of somebody
coming to power and ceasing to be
populist which is interesting because
all the time we are basically being fed
with these essential arguments about who
are you a population of fascism all
people change and somebody who is a
populist can turn into a fascist and
vice versa it's not an existential
condition is how you practice politics
in the position and empowered
and then we are studying these topics I
think in in a context of extreme abuse
of the concepts of the terms especially
populism populism
by what I will call aunty populist be I
mean let me be explicit here never voted
for a populist can denote I think I will
but I don't consider myself an anti
populist I mean I'm trying to study
basically why people like this which I
don't like but I'm not an anti popular
signs of the modernize that I mean and
the point is that in terms of the money
session people like I mean politicians
like the President of Mexico Pena Nieto
or former prime minister of free time
Tony Blair tend to identify populism
with whatever they don't like but I
might add what they mean is whatever
this against neoliberalism or the stock
to school and they believe they
represent so that is a kind of whenever
they talk they are talking out the
populace is everything that is not Tony
Blair or Enrique Pena Nieto now I was
wondering having studied the fascist for
a long time well how are the parties
responding to this and we saw I think
everybody saw that incredible buys
documentary right on Charlottesville and
one guy who had Theresa Trump supporter
there is a supporter of this broad
coalition between populism and fascism
in America said yeah but train is a
problem with Trump because he his
daughter is with a Jewish person so we
did you say he's not anti-semitic or
fascist enough for me that's you know
yeah an expert like me would say what
that's what this guy is saying and and
it's not their additional I was in a
container a couple of weeks ago and I
were I mean I'm one of those guys
actually and I don't know what they
think of me but I went today to his gift
to the newspaper stand
and I bought this fascist magazine and
they say somebody has to say the truth
it says they are all populist and
neoliberals so here unlike Blair or pena
nieto all the populist are the non
fascist according to the fascist bill
and yet the fascist as they we saw in
the documentary they can be taller than
to some extent of a populist racist in
power and actually that's preferable to
the end another joke
now the point is that the research
history behind this and the point is
that we need to understand this history
as a global history and what I mean what
I mean by that is that in terms of the
abuses of the term of all the terms
fascism and populism and understanding
of populism in history we need to really
go beyond our own country so that were
on places that that we study because for
example my colleagues studying Italy or
France know nobody that is here by the
way but I read some colleagues saying we
need to move back to the 1980s in order
to understand this connection between
populism and no fascism or to put it
differently the moment in which the
neo-fascist become populist and that is
totally correct if you just study France
and Italy but the question is when you
study the history in broader terms you
will see that in other places in the
world the populist the fascist and into
populist before why because of different
contexts it would have been unthinkable
to in the image of God in anti-fascist
context of a need of a country like
Italy or even current Germany it was
possible for example to do so and that
is what happened in Latin America okay I
have to disclose this is what I study
that's why I know the story I mean
basically it's not that I'm defending my
field but this is what I happen to know
that actually happened before that in
France or Italy I mean this transition
from fascism as a contestation of
democracy that destroys democracy from
within by always you know they win
elections they destroy democracy towards
very different situation in countries
like Brazil and Argentina where you have
dictators that happen after 1945
although they like fascism the guy from
my country Juan Domingo perón also like
anti-semitism handfuls of resistance but
he was also a politician a very smart
one and by 1945 he decided that instead
of destroying democracy from within in
fact he was a dictator who was a
strongman in a dictatorship he will
create a democracy out of dictatorship
so they opposite historical direction
now it's a good reason of the time so I
mean this is a Cold War
and here to live thin
that a pope you know let's say and I do
not see that is clearly clearly against
a liberal democracy cannot be legitimate
enough in the post in the coat in the
new early Cold War
so his fascist stance I mean he's in
power he sees that he will not be
successful he already sees how for
example Franco in the industry times
he's being surrounded and if you read
the papers by the way 1944 Indyk at
least in the countries that I've read
them in Europe or Latin America or in
the States everyone is talking that
Franco for example is going and this is
what Peron extinct in actually so the
point is that he like baragas and people
and also other leaders in Bolivia and
countries like Venezuela in a context in
which fascism was not defeated they
believe that they can recuperate some of
the Italian patterns of fascism for the
new world that emerges after 1945 now
why this is important for me it's
important because I'm not in American
this is part you know of the history I
study the history that affects my life
in many ways and so on and so forth but
this is important I think for all of us
because we particularly those that we
that are concerned out Trump today is
that these are the only pressures of
populism in power so you have to go to
the 1940s and 1950s to see the earlier
instances of what happens when a
populace is in power and you don't learn
that by studying what you know the
recent French elections or other things
I mean you don't learn that you I mean
the mode of learning is about populism
in the opposition which is in the
fantastic position of the nouns in
everything as they'll eat and talking
for the people this is one of the basic
definitions of populism that says a lot
and yet historical says nothing so
basically this is important I think to
you don't you think populism in terms of
its browser history this is what kind of
what I'm doing in this in this book and
and I will not like to kill my book in
the probably 10 minutes that I have but
I mean reduce it to to basically 10
minutes but I have to say that that is
one of my main arguments and a kind of
Falcon not the premise of their argument
not the premise at all but an Ultima of
that argument is that we have to be less
us center
les euro center to understand the
history of populism and it's not really
the premise it's not that I start on
this because this is my field and I want
to show my americanese colleagues or
your European history colleagues how
important is to know about migration I
mean that's not really the point
although of course I empathize with that
point but this is not my point is my
point is an outcome of my historical
investigation and basically that's why
it's important to understand this in
history Assad regime because I mean ISM
is interesting how it happens I mean in
a way with probably my rationale or
perhaps yours it's very difficult to
understand I mean how something which is
clearly contradictory I mean if you if
you're not in power I mean are you not
an elite are you really now being the
one being somehow overpowered by those
in power how do you explain that
and there are presence of how do you
explain that and in most cases actually
the idea is to push a further
polarization yes we are in power and we
see this in in Poland we see many this
in many countries
so the idea surprisingly enough and and
we know that this is the history in most
cases is that they choose to go in the
direction of polite polarization and
what they do with this with this
situation is then to explain that
although they are in power they are more
powerful enemies that you don't even can
defeat even if you are empowered so this
is the idea and that's why in all these
histories we see not in the definition
but in the histories there is a kind of
shared concern about the so-called
enemies of the people the president of
the US was not the present the first to
use this this conception and and I'm
pretty sure this that is he's very much
an interested in the history of the
phenomenon that he now represents so
what is interesting is how symptomatic
disease of a larger history of a
conversation of democracy so clearly
what I'm saying is the populace in green
I realized on enemies
clearly it's not that popular cannot you
know what happens when a populist is not
relying on this on the centrality or on
the centrality of the enemy well I will
say historically that broad
is ceasing to e or acting in populous
ways and this could have happened
you know when Trump owned election and
yet we have the car national speech in
which he basically they define his new
administration as one that will be
actually in a providing a sense of
continuity with the campaign and they
campaign I mean and this is you know
basically I said this I mean in my book
when I finish I had to finish it I
wanted to finish it and I said okay I
will I will restrict myself to analysis
of the campaign not really true I kind
of incorporated some further speeches
including this description of the end of
the present a new enemy of the people
but the truth of the matter is that I
think you know it will not be a stretch
I mean to say that historically at least
from my perspective it was a clearly
racist campaign nothing new in the
history of populism I mean there is a
basic distinction between populism on
the right and the left
they all talk of the people as in fact
those people that like them and vote for
them so the majority of citizens is
somehow translated transformed into
those that follow the leader
another European in a way myopia is that
because there are no they don't have
strong leaders in some opposition
European a movements populist movements
they say the leader is not important to
populism well I would say it's an
incomplete form of populism is in the
making so you need leaders for this
formation and when they--when and then
the second translation so the people who
are the people in this case a 30% more
or less that voted for Trump
those people become in fact the American
people and in a way Trump is ruling for
them now the second instance is of
course because as here Tony Salem this
is you know he's not the first in saying
this is that his dimension sure of the
people he's the one that is speaks for
the people the people that cannot speak
second translation so in fact in
practice the people are the leader so
the leader somehow embodies the people
and he through him that the people talk
and it's another form of consultation
that is not democratic at all because in
fact in so far as he knows what the
people think he doesn't need to ask
anyone what the people want
they are right it is what Hugh
and that's how he rules now he does not
in a context in which he relies on
electron legitimacy and that is why
populism is both democratic and
undemocratic at the same time it is a
form of authoritarian democracy so
populations relies on electoral ship
this machine
big difference with fascism now finally
to finish projects up to minutes I would
say okay so to finish I will say this I
mean the topic is how central democracy
is to populism it is centered it's a
form of legitimacy but what they want is
an illiberal democracy it is a democracy
that relies on formal elections which
they need to win and basically no other
instances of democracy meaning really
critical and lively public sphere and
independent press and the separation of
powers that is not important so it's a
kind of twisted form of democracy as my
colleague nari not to say a kind of
disfiguration of what democracy is but
it's not fascism which means the
elimination of democracy now trust ISM
proceedings fascism as you know I will
not talk about this is central to
fascism one way or the other I didn't
find in history a single case of fascism
in which racism or an ethnic notion of
of the people is not important and not
only in the sense of the definition of
the enemy but also in the specific sense
of excluding the enemy from citizenship
when they are in power so populism
doesn't do that populism demonizes them
the enemy on a rhetorical level but we
still can both right we might not be the
people but we still come both and our
role is important in a populist regime
because we demonstrate that we are the
constant losers now we're populism does
and this is what what I don't know and I
can tell you some presence a what
populism does when actually loses an
election it can cease to be populist and
I think this is what we are observing
now in Turkey and Venezuela and just
relying on more dictatorial forms of God
I mean they are not winning election I
mean in Venezuela Turkey's a different
story but in Venezuela they are being
unable to with free elections so
basically it's you know they are going
in the direction of dictatorship but
most populous in history don Dora
they just lose an edge
and they try to win the following one
and that's what basically happens but
what is in Tennessee is that populism
and this is probably the last two things
I would like to say populism is after
1945 when it becomes for the first time
and regime in so many Latin American
countries some of them I describe
basically it involves three a free fall
renunciation it involves a renunciation
of fascism which is a which in some
cases such as Peron in Argentina is
personal
he likes fascism he just doesn't think
that is possible a renunciation of
racism racism is to attach to the
violence of the Second World War and
basically doesn't work and in fact paid
on a pier on and this is interesting
paid on a he don't have a problem with
the Jewish umbrella organization why
because they weren't the Jewish umbrella
organization but what did he do unlike
Hitler he created a Pyrenees Jewish
organization and invited all owner
origins and Jews to be part of that so
you can be whatever you want but you e
you want to be or you need to be
parables or populist in this case the
other renunciation is political violence
in fact you know if you want to talk
about my country all the dictatorships
that we have and even other civilian
governments were much more violent than
the padrone's regime and finally what I
basically I think I said this three so
the renunciation of racism and to end
what I think is a novelty about trans
populism is that although we saw this
ethnic conception of the people which
defined the political enemies as known
member of let's say of the same fnot
typical group I mean this is typical in
Europe not much in a deal America by the
way in Latin America left and right
populism they are just not much of they
are not racist whereas in Europe we see
this in the opposition and we never saw
as far as I know in history a case in
which populism again tries to approach
fascism which means a renunciation of I
mean of the novelty of its or of
politics so basically what we have here
today and I don't know what is going to
happen obviously it's a novelty in the
sense that we have for the first time a
populism in power Dagobah
that goes back to a central tenet of
fascism is not fashion
yet I don't think it will be but who
knew Who am I to know the future
historians we are really wonderful
you know anticipating what is going to
happen but the point here is that we
have a performer population that as far
as I can tell is the closest to fascism
in power that we have in the history of
populism so I will finish with that salt
wonderful thank you all three of you so
much
you
[Music]